[Music]
they appeared to come out of nowhere but
extinction rebellion now has the power
to bring one of the world's most
powerful cities to a standstill so who
are they and what exactly do they want
[Music]
extinction rebellion or xrs they'd like
to be called officially formed in
October 2018 they say they expected a
couple of hundred people to show up to
their first protest in London but
instead around 1500 took to the streets
[Music]
they have to remain points they're
demanding first they want the government
to declare a climate and ecological
emergency next they want politicians to
act now and pledge to reduce greenhouse
gas emissions to Net Zero by 2025 and
finally they're calling for a citizen's
assembly to bring together people from
different communities to discuss climate
action
[Music]
they've been behind a number of
high-profile protests and stunts around
the UK from gluing themselves to trains
to blocking traffic in busy streets to
even protesting at Heathrow Airport and
delaying flights hundreds of people have
been arrested at these large and
disruptive protests they even tried to
spray fake blood over the Treasury
although that did not go as planned
XR activists are often extremely
apologetic for their disruptive actions
but insist that this is what they have
to do and while their stunts have
undoubtedly annoyed a lot of people many
in the growing climate activist movement
have been inspired it is yet to majorly
affect government legislation political
leaders have already pledged to cut
emissions to Net Zero but by 2050
considerably later than XR want an X our
protests have acknowledged their high
profile stunts and disruption could turn
the public against them despite 85% of
Brits admitting they are concerned about
the climate crisis this could be an
issue for extinction rebellion they say
they need three point five percent of
the population to actively engage in
nonviolent civil disobedience to
actually bring about political change
this may not sound like much but it
actually equates to 2.3 million people
on the streets
that might sound unrealistic but XR
believes it is possible and they
certainly have enough support to cause
serious disturbances around the country
that should put it to the test
the public's appetite for disruption